176 años es el tiempo que pasó para que
una mujer se convirtiera en la jefa del
Departamento de Policía de Nueva York se
trata x-sensual quien hasta el momento
se desempeñaba como la jefe detectives
del condado de Nassau en esta ciudad en
este momento he completado un ciclo y es
con un corazón humilde y los ojos sobre
las tareas y los desafíos que tengo por
delante que acepto el puesto de
comisionado de policía de la ciudad de
Nueva York
policía oficial de detective y
ahora tendrá el deber de dirigir la
fuerza policial más grande de Estados
Unidos con cerca de 35000 oficiales
nombramiento del alcalde electo de Nueva
York
estoy muy orgulloso en este día y acabar
con barreras está increíble profesional
de la aplicación de la ley
llevo consigo a lo largo de su carrera
un mazo y acabo con todo el límite es
que se interpusieron en su camino
[Música]
hoy destruyó el último que necesitábamos
para la ciudad de Nueva York
sueldo de 49 años y nacida en Queens
llegará supuesto este primero de enero y
tendrá la tarea de reformar a la policía
tocada por las manifestaciones en contra
del racismo al mismo tiempo deberá
encontrar soluciones para contener la
ola de violencia que invadió las calles
de la Gran Manzana desde que comenzó la
pandemia